the most challenging one of all of them
was was cap this kind of guy out of time
and
is it too retro are people gonna get it
and with evans and johnson the first
time around it was like
yes we get it and you get it and you
like it initially i'm just trying to
build a foundation of who this guy is
but you feel like you know the character
now
the first captain america film is
subtitled the first avenger because
that's really what cap is
born out of the technology of the 1940s
frozen ice
coming back into the present day he then
goes into the avengers and you realize
in a lot of ways he's the moral backbone
of the avengers
how do we do this as a team
hey everybody it's charlie everybody's
freaking out about chris evans tweet
saying goodbye to his character captain
america so i'll explain what's going on
but it's one of those captain america
memes so you thought you could say
goodbye and everyone wouldn't lose their
[ __ ]
yes it confirms a couple things but i
think a couple people are taking his
quote just a little
too far so no worries it's new york
comic con week there's a bunch of news
going on like this there's a new round
of that spider-man ps4
game giveaway to all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber
and leave a captain america related
comment on the video
his actual quote reads officially
wrapped on avengers 4
it was an emotional day to say the least
playing this role over the last 8 years
has been an
honor to everyone in front of the camera
behind the camera
and in the audience thank you for the
memories eternally grateful
so even if you haven't been following
the saga of chris evans contract
behind the scenes this feels like a very
final goodbye like he's taking his bow
to the audience
thank you everyone involved in the
making of this character in bringing him
to life
it's been an honor goodbye we already
know that a lot of the phase one
avengers are gonna be transitioning
into the background during phase four
some of them will get more movies and
continue on just like normal
we know there's a black widow movie that
they're making that's set in the past
we know chris hemsworth wants to do more
thor given the right script so he'll
come back eventually
there are a couple characters that are
on the fence there's been talk of them
doing a hawkeye movie
with a female version of hawkeye like
doing a transitional where he passes the
mantle to her from the fraction run
marvel just announced that they're doing
a loki project with tom hiddleston and
the scarlet witch project with elizabeth
olsen
so just remember even though this seems
like captain america will not continue
forward in the timeline
it might not be the last time that chris
evans plays the character
because they do so many movies said in
the past and because of things like iron
man's b-a-r-f-ing technology where you
look at your memories of a character so
even though they're not alive they can
be walking around on screen
i included that spider-man homecoming
meme that's actually a really good
example of new footage they shot with
chris evans
but it wasn't actually captain america
walking around in present day with the
spider-man character
it was new footage shot as stock footage
that he had shot some time after the
first avengers movie
so just because this is the end of
captain america forward in the timeline
it doesn't mean it's the absolute
hard end of captain america within the
marvel cinematic universe
the next big thing is that what does
that mean for his arc during avengers 4
so if you haven't been catching up with
the reshoots the funny thing that mark
ruffalo just revealed a little while ago
is that when they did their principal
photography
they didn't finish the movie the russos
didn't know what their ending was and
they weren't quite sure what a lot of
their big plot points were going to be
so they scheduled the reshoot so that
they could make all those decisions
because you have to lock picture at a
certain point so they can finish special
effects and it becomes an actual movie
because it sounded like they just had a
bunch of big moments and a couple big
action scenes
but no real narrative thread figured out
that's why the last couple of weeks
you've been hearing different actors say
they've wrapped on avengers 4. so like
iron man is still on set pepper potts is
still on set but they filmed things
out of order so just because certain
characters rap before
others doesn't necessarily mean that
everyone's safe or everyone dies
i've said it a long time ago i felt like
captain america was at the top of my
death predictions just because chris
evans
is a character who's a soldier he
doesn't trade lives that was one of the
big quotes of infinity war
and he is the first person to throw
himself on a grenade like it goes all
the way back to that first avenger movie
there's a little more going on with
iron man's arc because they set up the
pepper potts teaser about the wedding
and the baby he thinks that they're
having but they also set up the captain
america threat he still hasn't made good
with him
so captain america's biggest arc aside
from just saving the universe in general
is is in resolving the conflict with
iron man there was so much stuff going
on in infinity war that's why they never
met they just saved that for avengers 4
so that's when they come to terms like
we've seen captain america on set
without the beard obviously some time
has passed
the whole idea of the movie is is that
they come together and learn to be true
heroes a true
team like that quote that chris evans
had during that promo at the beginning
where they're reflecting on the captain
america character
how do we do this together so when red
skull is telling thanos that in order to
wield the soul stone you have to give up
something that you love not necessarily
the thing that you love
in a romantic sense because when people
started thinking about how iron man
might be able to use the gauntlet to
save everyone
they thought oh does that mean that
he'll have to sacrifice pepper because
he loves her most are getting
ready to get married the twist i think
is that when they resolve that captain
america iron man arc
they'll love each other like brothers
and captain america will throw himself
on the grenade again and sacrifice
himself so that tony can wield the soul
stone and bring everyone back that was
turned to ash
meaning that iron man would survive
because there was a deleted scene where
they went a little bit longer talking
about the wedding foreshadowing what was
going to happen
i think that they'll end the movie with
the wedding
and a memorial for captain america's
character so you do have kind of a
downer
because it is sad that he would die but
you really end on a happy moment
at the same time so you kind of balance
it out because i don't think they want a
downer ending because you got the downer
ending at the end of infinity war
oh god what are we going to do avengers
is meant to wrap up all the last 10
years of marvel movies they're not gonna
do that on a huge
bummer so not including the post-credits
scenes which i think will be some fun
stuff i think the wedding
is like the actual final part of the
film if you want any more evidence that
chris evans isn't coming back though
robert downey jr
in real life had a really special custom
captain america themed car made for
chris evans
now he is very generous he gives people
gifts but this is like a
crazy expensive gift and jay leno when
he was talking about it
learned that robert danny jr himself
flew out to the place
where they make these cars made all
these hand decisions picked all the
colors the fabric
everything was totally involved with the
making of the car as if it was his own
special personal project
why would robert downey jr do that if it
weren't meant to be
a going-away present like this is it for
you you've had this amazing run you're a
great person
so we're gonna honor it by giving you
this captain america car
it's actually a really badass car now
iron man on the other hand i think he is
transitioning to a background role but
there are ways that you can keep tony
alive and still use him without needing
him to be on screen all the time
kevin feige also has that quote where he
says captain america is like the moral
center of the avengers you could say
he's the soul
of the avengers and iron man is the
heart of the avengers
so whereas infinity war was all about
thanos mission
his heart and soul it's all about iron
man and captain america's heart and soul
and avengers 4.
then bridging that gap coming together
as a team and then obviously teeing up
what's going to be happening in phase 4
with some of these new characters like
captain of marvel
spider-man stepping up in a big way
spider-man far from home is all about
him being an agent of shield pretty much
like him working with nick fury his new
black costume even has a shield symbol
on it i'll talk about that during a
separate spider-man video because it's
actually pretty cool
but just to be clear chris evans isn't
leaving because he doesn't like making
marvel movies i think he just feels like
his character arc is up he's a director
he wants to direct movies and he can't
do that when he's busy doing this
so he just has a lot of his own personal
projects that he wants to spend his time
developing
so let me know in the comments how do
you want them to say goodbye to captain
america
during avengers 4. it's new york comic
con week there's a whole bunch of venom
videos that i'm getting ready to post
post credits easter eggs all that stuff
i'll name a new giveaway winner when i
post new marvel
click here for my non-spoilery venom
review and click here for that brand new
daredevil season 3
bullseye trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]